le ps sera officiellement présenté mardi
prochain à 11h lors de la première
réunion du cs le comité social et
économique
mais la direction a d'ores et déjà
annoncé la couleur 127 emplois sur les
520 que compte le site sont concernés de
quoi inquiéter de nombreux salariés ont
fait de notre mieux on à fond mais
l'état d'esprit est pas terrible quoi
est-ce que ça va te les copains savez
tout ça on sait pas c'est flou mais
c'est terrible ça peut aussi impacter
votre vie personnelle abattu tôt fait
vous savez j'ai qu'un salaire alors si
c'est moi je sais pas comment j'ai fait
quoi oui mais il faut quand même à salir
il faut tous se sont certes longue tout
ça plombe tout non mais vous pourriez
vous aller travailler ailleurs par
exemple les 54 ans pour l'instant je
n'envisage pas tôt l'entreprise parisot
a été placé en redressement judiciaire
le 5 juin 2019 par le tribunal de
commerce de dijon
la direction se donnaient alors six mois
pour améliorer sa situation et tenter de
trouver des repreneurs
en vain malgré l'amélioration des
résultats de la société ces derniers
demeurent négatifs le marché du meuble
reste compliquée et le carnet de
commandes est inférieur à nos prévisions
la situation la trésorerie de la société
nous contraint désormais à faire un
choix de gestion difficile
un choix difficile accepter par le maire
de la commune
s'il concède qu'il y aura bien un impact
sur les commerces
thierry bordeaux voit ce pse comme une
chance de rebondir
on est face au principe de réalité des
réalités de marché qui sait que voilà il
ya dix ans une entreprise en grande
difficulté aujourd'hui
maintenant on peut dire ce qu'on veut
notre devoir c'est ta compagnie à la
fois d'entreprises à la fois des
salariés à la fois de territoire pour
retrouver un élan qui permet de tirer
vers le haut mardi une heure avant le
cso les syndicats et les salariés se
réuniront devant le site
parce que eux sont forcément contre